mieux aux demandes c'est squeeze
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur 1916 1,9
insiste à vue nous on va mettre déjà en
anglais dans un premier temps star c'est
parti c'est un jeu qui se passe à la
première guerre mondiale nous sommes
dans les tranchées et d'après ce que
j'ai lu il y a des choses qui vont se
mêler à cette histoire trouve l'échelle
oui puisque je parle couramment allemand
s'est notamment dit rice vahid raï fir
four voilà un deux trois quatre cinq et
ont peu de reggae avec ces mots sans
déconner vraiment c'est vrai il m'arrive
des fois de séduire des allemandes juste
en comptant jusqu'à 5 voilà bon je le
dis c'est joli graphiquement c'est pas
mal du tout il ya des bruits patrick
houle aequo et court tu as un ninja
région d'haillicourt lebron arrière
comme comme naruto hoya truqués passé
mouillé en courant qui était c'est la
batmobile à une note
oui prend la note prends tu fais quoi
mais qu à eux relâche la note tout de
suite boîte quelqu'un nickel attendre
lui arrache son pied quoi deux camarades
scaron pas gentil et ben écoute mec
merci est décédé pour permettre
peut-être de vivre à bientôt aller vers
dit jeter son pied pu terminer on pas
déjà
tu vas me quoi m'appeler notre pote
n'aura pas d'impact mec c'était quoi ce
bordel c'est un didot et vannes où il va
nous pêchons par derrière voilà je tiens
le pied j'ai dansé pieds à la va vite
chaud pour rien ce qui se passe c'est ce
mec a décoré comme naruto peut-être
qu'on pourrait mieux comprendre la
droite ya quoi ré à ckoi se brouillent
un séisme en même temps qu'est ce qui se
passe là oh oui on va trouver une maison
au port aux eaux à bonjour piano oui
quelqu'un à aimer ce morceau ou pas hein
et ben voilà écoutez je vends des
singles et piémont de caunes a racheté
les et toi tu veux pas me passer un
petit morceau de à voilà du morceau de
pied par exemple c'est pas mal mais
qu'est ce que foutent des dinosaures ce
proverbe garde genou testé je veux
vraiment me tester
je me suis défoncé le coup mais on fait
quoi avec cet homme c'est un squelette
ok tu as gagné un batteur calme-toi bon
résultat à lille car enfin ce portable
il n'y avait pas fair play ou du même
pas bien joué quand tu dansais pour vous
enfoncer choix qui a une histoire de au
traducteur allemand s'il vous plaît
voilà moi que je vous ai dit je drague
les filles allemande mais avec juste un
couteau jusqu'à 5 2 il n'ya pas une map
un truc une map m
nansion m pour vers la guerre dont les
jeux c'est normal parce que m com/maps
voilà ce que pour moi ok donc on ramasse
les membres de the pop grenade on est
une grenade mon gars non non lâche la
main tiens je vais envoyer la main c'est
scandaleux
je ne tiens je sais pas où au courant
comme la route au oui eh bien vous quel
média avec ceux qui tiraient ok moi j'ai
lancé une grenade jours ci une grenade
dessus comme ça ça lui a fait peur vous
pensez et si offert une battle de danse
lui aussi bon on va se marrer dans tous
les cas claudia bunker honvault bunker
ah ben on arrête un moment plus tard
wendel à je suis dans leur nid oui vite
un bunker au brouillard ou s'est sauvé
tranquillement on est posée aux voilà
tout ça pour trouver une échelle pour
s'enfuir l'instant relaxation faut la
changer
merci pour ton fusil je peux tirer avec
ont pas eu tous j'ai encore des balles
ou par des arias débat là regardez donc
là dans cette zone et du gaz
donc il nous faudrait le masque à gaz
comme les gars si on réussit sujet c'est
incroyable encore on a récupéré un
masque à gaz dans la zone vol at on
retourne à wimbledon mina et on peut
s'enfuir par la petite échelle en bois
qui nous vient tout droit de jouer club
c'est quoi une lettre oui ok c'est parti
j'eus a déjà plus de ce que je dois me
dire oh qu'est ce qui se passe bitches
il craint pas des balles ok c'est pas
par là je suis caché je vais me cacher
la voilà ce parfait il a voulu monter
sur mon dos mais nous s est pas simple à
sans déconner bordel on va réussir
là il faut aller à louise yahoo claudia
jeu c'est plus une catastrophe cette
organisation je veux nommer quelqu'un
responsable organisation toi tu resteras
l'organisation voilà ce que veut dire
que truc à dire cette vidéo ce
responsable organisation et vous me
dites vous me dites quel chemin prendre
voilà j'attends là ça permet d'aller où
nathalie ça c'est nouveau ça ok qu'il
n'y a pas assez on est à nathalie
l'eonia je sais pas où je vais m'en bats
les steaks un piège était jetée en
piémont gars donc là c'est nous amène
tout droit dans le cul du diable excusez
moi à la c koi oui ménard louisiane
louisiane dans un bunker
le bruit total claudia bunker c'est par
là ok on est chez claudia le bunker le
vainqueur
le vainqueur qui se passait et téléphone
arabe alors que je suis seul l'allemagne
sera ok at et des gongs athée day 1c
savate ans et des robots en fait très
bien alors give me your weapon attend
non mais comment je change d'armes
ça va être comme ça à nampula marot pour
la barre jamais pro les deux je sais que
je peux giflé quelqu'un mais est une
autre main que la mienne conseil pourra
pas dire à sa maman arrive à taper et
c'est pas moi bah moi c'est la main
bompard le dire bizarre allez c'est
l'heure de sortir du bunker je crois
qu'il soit encore en fout on se casse
alors là maintenant il faut aller ou non
pardon j'avais la main il faut qu'on
sorte on aille à gauche gauche droite
gauche gauche c'est parti six questions
gauche on doit être là puis droite puis
gauche puis gauche ok je suis déjà perdu
[ __ ] oui monsieur mila louise ya c'est
la louisiane c'est par là ok c'est là on
trouvera le masque à gaz au shit cet
acte et je suis avec vous les amis donc
c'est gauche droite c'est la vie gauche
non non il faut céder à la tentation
on va ramasser une petite main il aura
envie banon ou alors il a envie mais il
me manque un pied encore plus qu'avant
elle et on arrive à louise ya louisa bon
maire louise
voilà pour rate et par là je sens qu'on
n'est pas loin je peux sentir cette
odeur de matériaux utilisés pour créer
des masques à gaz c'est l'amour au oui
c'est la meilleure et je mets comment
avec g je crois ok ok possédez-vous la
masque à gaz lui un barnum s'il n'a pas
de poumons c'est un [ __ ] de robots ok
donc là il faut que j'aille à richmond
bah je sais plus le nom bordel et
obtient ce que dément le mans déjà qu'en
france on a du mal wilhelmina on y va et
pourquoi pas nous il ya des fans une
fois sur dix quoi c'est scandaleux
wilhelmina bienvenus tiens un pied je
m'en vais vite vazia gaz de co2 le
peuple est ainsi qu aux chemins je ne me
souviens plus on va y aller au filet
samba les ago la balle temps on n'a pas
le temps de réfléchir aux chemins où on
est et guerrier on y va comme ça au lac
et and later
c'est comme en anglais c'est à dire plus
tard n'en tire pas sur le pad ou c'est
pas nouveau c'est je te jure c'est pas
le moment
courrent m ralph mauvaise série the
official in front of you
[Musique]
alors alors ils courent hypothèse espace
web ninjas sont incroyables quoi naruto
après la guerre mondiale h au nom c'est
un dieu qui nous a eus nom ne dit pas
qu'il a croqué notre steak
nous sommes tous des steaks au nom il a
une autre siècle ville à la grosse comme
ça sur votre cuisse c'est pas nous qui
nous battons les steaks ces pluies et
vous compris jeu de mot de passe que
parfois les blacks sont tellement nu
comme dans les expliquer hockey et voilà
on a fini le jeu en 16 minutes on
s'applaudit merci à françois pour son
arme bunter et mafia françoise dont son
masque à gaz par terre dans la boue en
tout cas j'ai prêché nous a plus c'est
le cas n'était pas vu la vidéo comme
d'habitude c'est un jeu vraiment
original en plus graphiquement il un peu
spécial c'est un peu dans des teintes
hop sombre et obscures avec du noir et
du glee c'est vachement sympa j'ai bien
aimé jaune 1916 lindois d'espions si
vous voulez vous le faire mais c'est
peut-être les dinosaures qui auront
raison de vous on se retrouvait dans une
nouvelle vidéo westergaard et chats tout
le monde pissas
[Musique]